[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est vous Mohamed Bida
bonjour bienvenue sur ce plateau vous
êtes commandant divisionnaire honoraires
de police vous avez été l'un des
principaux responsables de la sécurité
de l'ambassade de France à Kaboul entre
2016 et 2021 13 jours et 13 nuits dans
l'enfer de Kaboul c'est le récit
absolument dingue que vous signez chez
de Noël de l'incroyable opération
d'évacuation que vous avez piloté entre
le 15 et le 27 de ce mois d'août 2021
nous sommes le 15 août 2021 il faut dire
que vous êtes à quelques semaines de la
retraite Kaboul c'est votre dernier
poste et ce 15 août la capitale afghane
tombe au moins des talibans après une
offensive éclair et rien après cette
date ne va se passer comme prévu
absolument
ce fameux 15 août nous étions préparé à
évacuer l'Afghanistan puisque nous
savions déjà depuis plusieurs jours que
la situation allait dégénérée
l'ambassade de France avait pris sa
disposition on avait anticipé
l'évacuation de nos employés afghan de
leur famille et les personnels de
l'ambassade était en effectif réduit
alors ce qui est la planification avait
été menée à son terme mais en revanche
qui n'avait pas été prévu c'est
effectivement non pas l'arrivée des
talibans parce qu'on savait que c'était
un livre arriverait un jour ou l'autre
mais c'est la volonté le désir de fuir
le leur pays des Afghans qui étaient
terrifiés mais l'idée de vivre à nouveau
sous un régime taliban voilà au fil des
heures après la chute de Kaboul
convergent vers l'ambassade de France
qui est à ce moment là la dernière
ambassade de la Greenson de la zone
verte à être encore ouverte non
seulement des Français qui n'ont pas
encore évacué mais aussi des Afghans qui
vous demandent de l'aide et là la
question qui se pose c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on fait c'est tout le paradoxe de
cette histoire puisque effectivement
nous avons été les premiers à anticiper
à évacuer
sans critique absolument et nous serons
les derniers à partir parce que nous
avons cette obligation morale de
d'assister les Français qui sont encore
présents à Kaboul mais aussi quelques
afghans qui avaient demandé déjà à
partir et qui va obtenir des visas pour
ça et ce sont agrégés à ce dispositif
des centaines voire des milliers
d'Afghans qui ont congé dans la zone
verte et la seule ambassade en cours
ouverte donc ambassade de France des
gens qui pour la plupart venaient de
Kaboul voire même de province puisqu'on
avait pas très loin de l'ambassade d'un
parc public où s'est-il réfugié des
milliers de personnes qui avaient fui
les provinces afghane qui étaient sous
le feu des aliments et c'est imposé à
nous rapidement
une nécessité c'était de mettre l'abri
tous ces gens qui étaient devant le
portails de l'ambassade l'ambassadeur
David Martineau fait donc ouvrir les
portes de l'ambassade vous vous
retrouvez à 100 200 300 jusqu'à combien
de personnes
vous comprenez vite avec la dizaine
d'hommes de sécurité qui sont encore là
qu'il va falloir vous débrouiller tout
seul sans l'aide des Américains pour
quitter le pays c'est par les airs
encore faut-il arriver jusqu'à
l'aéroport de Kaboul qui a combien de
kilomètres dans l'ambassade
un vol d'oiseau à peine 8 km et
l'itinéraire seront plus longs puisqu'il
va falloir emprunter d'autres chemins et
voilà donc il faut vous vous dites qu'il
faut transporter tous ces civils jusqu'à
l'aéroport et vous vous dites que vous
allez les emmener en bus déjà idée idée
assez assez incroyable et chose
impossible sans aller négocier avec les
talibans exactement c'est vrai que nous
dépendions énormément de la logistique
américaine la logistique militaire
notamment et Dieu sait que les
Américains ont fait beaucoup pour la
communauté étrangère à Kaboul mais le
tir d'arme automatique sur les
hélicoptères américains étaient
évidemment quelque chose d'impensable et
c'est arrivé donc les Américains ont
suspendu et annulé finalement toutes les
opérations d'évacuation donc pour moi il
était évident que le seul moyen
rejoindre l'aéroport malgré toutes les
tous les projets qui ont été initiés par
l'ambassadeur avec l'ambassadeur
américain notamment pour essayer de nous
sortir de cette enfer c'était par
l'avoir routière d'avoir routière et
malheureusement il nous fallait des
moyens que nous n'avions pas des bus
effectivement ça paraît un peu ce gros
nu comme comme solution mais c'est le
meilleur moyen de transport de la grande
capacité que nous avions et je savais
comment Kaboul il y avait des bus même
s'il n'y a pas de société de location ça
n'existe pas à Kaboul mais il y a
énormément de chauffeurs indépendants et
des bus qui traversent toute la ville et
avec les gens qui étaient déjà dans
l'ambassade notamment notre traducteur
c'est sa probité traducteur donc Wally
nous avons fait appel à ces chauffeurs
un par un par téléphone et planifier
avec eux donc le départ de l'ambassade
mais en négociant également avec le
responsable du checkpoint qui était le
checkpoint de l'ambassade de France un
taliban qui détenait lui la clé
du verrou de ce checkpoint et un de vos
interlocuteurs
variable qui est un aliment vous demande
un visa pour partir exactement c'est une
chose qui met des paru totalement
impensable mais c'est vrai que ce
taliban a souhaité quitter son pays
également il ne voulait pas comme il me
l'a dit vivre dans ce pays avec on les
désignant d'ailleurs il désigner ses
propres collègues qui étaient devant moi
ou à 200 mètres sur le checkpoint il
voulait pas vivre avec ces gens-là me
disait-il qu'ils voulaient vous les
doigts absolument donner un avenir à ses
enfants et vivre paisiblement donc c'est
assez surprenant mais en même temps les
talibans font partie du peuple encore
puisque ce sont des Afghans et le régime
de taliban fait peur également à ceux
qui rallye ce régime parfois contraints
et forcés vous finissez par arriver à
l'aéroport non sans mal je laisse les
téléspectateurs lire le récit de ses
heures pendant lesquelles ce qu'on voit
a fini par arriver à l'aéroport c'est
assez stupéfiant et là ce que vous
découvrez à l'aéroport de Kaboul ce sont
des scènes d'apocalypse je lis un
extrait de votre livre je m'attendais au
chaos je découvre une scène d'apocalypse
une de fin du monde de celles que l'on
voit dans les films d'anticipation ou
seuls quelques élus peuvent rejoindre
l'arche tandis que les autres tentent
vainement d'y monter au périls de leur
vie c'est ça l'aéroport de Kaboul on est
le 17 18 août nous sommes le 18 août au
petit matin je découvre ces paysages
autour de moi paysage de barbelés de
femmes d'enfants d'hommes en cheveux
très dans ses dans ses amas de ferraille
avec des soldats américains qui
évidemment ont la mission de sécuriser
l'entrée de l'aéroport mais aussi des
Afghans des services de renseignement
aveuglants qui se sont improvisés
en maintien de l'ordre et maintiennent
leur très violent très très violent
j'ai eu du mal à décrire les situations
que j'avais sous les yeux parce
qu'effectivement je voyais des femmes
des enfants se faire tirer dessus à la
balle plastique des grenades
lacrymogènes je ne sais au milieu de la
foule et des hommes frappés à coups de
bâton femme enfant sans distinction
vieillard
et ces gens qui étaient dans un état
d'hystérie collective
terrorisé à l'idée de rester dans ce
pays qui n'ont pas hésité à se jeter
dans des barbelés et à passer parfois
trois ou quatre jours dans ce contexte
on se souvient des images de l'aéroport
alors votre mission continue après
l'opération d'évacuation par bus ce
qu'il vous faut là c'est trouver dans
les milliers de personnes qui
s'entassent dans ce CLOA donc dans
l'aéroport
ceux qui sont évacuables disons mais
vous avez ni photo ni numéro et c'est à
ce moment là qui va être prise une photo
qui a fait le tour du monde et qui a été
notamment postée par votre ambassadeur
David Martine Honde vous êtes dans une
espèce de fosse septique à ciel ouvert
racontez-nous et vous tirez par le bras
une femme exactement c'est je crois
qu'on est au 5e ou 6e jour des
opérations de d'extiltration de gens
qu'on essaie de trouver ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre que
il y avait des milliers de personnes
autour de ces aéroports qui souhaitaient
évidemment prendre la fuite mais il y a
énormément d'afgans à travers tout le
pays qui aurait aimé être dans cette
situation et là je pèse mes mots quand
je dis émettre dans ces situations c'est
pouvoir avoir au moins une issue de
sortie et pouvoir quitter ce pays et en
l'occurrence cette photo est prise par
un ancien interprète de l'armée
française un Afghan que je venais
chercher mais je ne trouvais pas au
milieu de cette foule on ne pouvait pas
identifier les gens et lui il m'a
identifié à cause du badge que je porte
sur le gilet pare-balle et il se rend
compte que ces ambassade de France et il
me prend en photo il envoie cette photo
à Paris un de ses contacts au ministère
de la Défense à Paris qui nous renvoie
cette photo en disant voilà il était là
où vous avez extrait cette femme cette
femme donc qui se trouvait là
c'est pas sur des listes c'est une femme
que l'on connaissait pas mais à ce
moment là c'est passé une scène assez
assez tragique elle était avec ses trois
enfants dont un nourrissant qui a été
qui s'est retrouvé dans l'eau bousculé
par la foule et avec mes deux collègues
puisqu'on nous sommes deux on les voit
pas sur la photo malheureusement mais on
explique cette femme et ses enfants
et cette femme aujourd'hui j'ai eu la
grande surprise il y a trois semaines de
découvrir qu'elle vivait en France et
que son fils était un ancien assistant
de l'AFP à Kaboul et donc maintenant je
sais qui est cette femme et elle vous
doit peut-être la vie je voulais vous
montrer une autre photo Mohamed Bida
vous connaissez peut-être pas elle a été
prise toujours à l'aéroport de Kaboul ce
qu'il faut dire à noter les spectateurs
ce que vous racontez dans votre livre
c'est que votre nom était devenu une
certaine façon un sésame et cet afghan
là il a écrit votre nom sur la pancarte
qui tient un bout de bras je ne sais pas
si vous vous souvenez de lui mais lui se
souvient de vous il s'appelle Tyer
paiman il a 28 ans il est aujourd'hui à
Strasbourg et c'est Sonia guezzali notre
correspondante à Kaboul qui m'a envoyé
cette photo qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque
et effectivement d'ailleurs il a des
foulards rouges également entre ce que
c'était le premier signe de distinction
qu'on leur avait demandé de porter mais
rapidement la foule c'est également
approprié ces signes qui permettaient
d'identifier les Afghans qu'on venaient
les chercher et j'ai découvert
effectivement cette affiche avec mon nom
et puis le l'ambassade de France mais
très rapidement aussi cette affiche a
fait le tour du canal et on s'est
retrouvé avec des centaines de personnes
qui qui portaient ce type de signes de
reconnaissance en tout cas l'huile c'est
ce qui vous doit rentrer en 13 jours
plus de 3000 personnes ont été évacuées
par les services français dont à peu
près un millier d'enfants vous quittez
Kaboul le 27 août avec quel sentiment
celui du devoir accompli
c'est des sentiments très partagés avec
beaucoup d'amertume beaucoup d'amertume
parce qu'on a le sentiment de ne pas
avoir fait assez
soulagement parce que c'est deux
semaines de pression intense mais
pressions qui avaient commencé bien
avant puisque dès la fin juillet on
savait que les événements étaient en
train de dégénérer
soulagement et amertume ils nous ont
hanté ce que vous n'avez pas pu sauver
pendant quelques jours après mon retour
en France oui j'ai eu des nuits assez
assez perturbé mais moi j'ai en tête
toujours une phrase de mes collègues qui
au moment où on nous a demandé de
quitter Kaboul donc l'ordre a été donné
nous a été donné d'évacuer il m'a
regardé il m'a dit on a fait ce qu'on a
pu et en réalité c'est ce qui s'est
passé on a fait ce qu'on a pu on a
évacuer à peu près 3000 personnes qu'on
a pu récupérer on aurait peut-être pu
faire plus faire ça nous auront
prochainement avoir fait trop d'autre
pas assez mais je crois que dans ces
conditions
il est il est difficile de porter un
jugement sur l'action qu'on a pu porter
contraire moi je pense que la France est
honorée de faire ce qu'elle a fait à ce
moment-là vous avez passé cinq ans dans
un Afghanistan
qui est taliban avant
ce que ce pays existe toujours pour vous
et qu'est-ce que ça vous fait de voir
aujourd'hui ce que subit ce peuple ces
jeunes femmes ces jeunes filles privées
d'école et cette famille notamment qui
rôde
aujourd'hui je suis assez dépité de la
situation mais en même temps on se dit
qu'on est on y a passé 20 ans il n'y a
pas ses 20 ans et il faut simplement se
souvenir pour quelle raison nous sommes
allés en Afghanistan c'est à cause des
attentats du 11 septembre non pas pour
défendre le droit des femmes qui étaient
déjà bafouées depuis 1996 pendant les
cinq années de pouvoir des talibans on a
vu les exactions des scènes de
lapination je dirais même que la
destruction des blouses Bamian avait
suscité plus d'opinions plus d'émotions
dans l'opinion publique internationale
que le sort des femmes donc aujourd'hui
ce qui se passe avec les talibans n'est
pas une vraie surprise mais je pense
qu'on a encore les moyens de mettre la
pression sur cet aliment qui ont besoin
de toute façon de l'aide internationale
ils ont une situation de famille une
situation sociale qui est totalement
dégradée et aujourd'hui
je pense que je serai prêt à des
concessions si le comité internationale
accepte de négocier avec eux je crois
qu'on a la solution très très proche et
en même temps ce qui se passe en Iran
comment ça faire ça en Afghanistan mais
c'est vrai qu'on est peut-être à la
veille d'un bouleversement dans ce pays
ou des femmes comme en Iran on est en
train de modifier le paysage
et si les hommes en Afghanistan ne
blessent pas comme en Iran parce que
c'est ça le symbolique c'est que en Iran
les hommes sont au côté des femmes c'est
pas le cas on Afghanistan mais ça peut
arriver on continue à parler
d'Afghanistan sur France 24 bien sûr on
n'oublie pas merci infiniment Mohamed
vida d'être venu ce matin sur ce plateau
pour ce récit absolument exceptionnel 13
jours et très nuit dans le 13 nuits dans
l'enfer de Kaboul chez de Noël à hauteur
d'hommes qui remet des noms et des
visages sur des images terribles d'août
2021 remercie et on pense à Sonia
guezzali notre correspondante à Kaboul
donc vous connaissez l'estime qu'elle
vous porte merci encore